sixth concept is transnationalism
professor harold koh now State
Department legal counsel is perhaps the
leading proponent of what he describes
as transnationalism he compares this
with what he describes as the
Nationalists philosophy that is somehow
taken hold of American law for the past
two hundred and twenty years he says
trans nationalists tend to believe in
the political and economic
interdependence of nations while
nationalists focus instead on preserving
United States autonomy the trans
nationalists recognize that
international domestic law are merging
into a hybrid body of transnational law
while nationalists preserve a rigid
division between domestic and foreign
law trans nationalists believe that
domestic courts have a role to play in
incorporating international law into
domestic law while nationalists complain
that only the political branches are
authorized to domesticate international
legal norms professor Co remember the
council the legal counsel at the State
Department now predicts to the clash
between competing visions of
constitutional laws he describes them
between transnationalism and nationalism
will play out in future Supreme Court
confirmation hearings and that these
will be pivotal in determining by the
year twenty twenty the direction in
which the United States's States law
proceeds he says what the United States
in the world will look like if we just
let constitutional change happen and
what it will look like if we seize this
moment to push our constitutionalism and
our policies and better directions will
be at stake in the next few Supreme
Court confirmations in practice
transnationalism would legitimize
reliance by American judges upon foreign
law in giving meaning to the United
States Constitution it would bind
federal and state governments to
international treaties and agreements
that had never been
ratified by the United States much less
enacted into law by Congress it would
render both the domestic and
international conduct of the u.s.
increasingly beholden to the review and
judgment of international tribution the
tribunals and geneva and the hague it
would expose american soldiers and
elected leaders to the sanctions of
international law for imagined war
crimes and violations of the earth and
would once again replace the judgments
of officials representing the American
people in holding paramount the interest
of the United States of America with the
judgments of European bureaucrats and
multinational panels of judges finally
and precisely balancing the interests of
this country with the interest of
authoritarians and dictators throughout
the world